[Music]
continuing through phase three we
introduced dr. strange you need a
spectacular actor to portray this
character in the fact that Benedict
Cumberbatch has agreed to do this role
is huge friends Benedict he's got an
incredibly complicated emotional
structure going on it's one of the
things that's important to us in telling
a magical story is keeping it rounded
but still leaving enough room to have
really cool and unique visual ideas to
explore
what you can expect from this Doctor
Strange movie is a mind trip action
though how do you put that on a screen
within this cinematic universe that is
you know one of the primary goals that
movie
hey youtubers is charlie so you guys may
have seen some of the doctor strange
stuff running around Benedict
Cumberbatch buying comics in his doctor
strange costume they actually just
tweeted that they pretty much film
principal photography all that means is
that they finished principal photography
they're editing the film now they'll do
reshoots later so there's still a lot of
work to be done in the film but they
probably got like eighty percent of the
footage that they need usually when
reshoots happen on a film it's just
because there's dialogue that's missing
or they need a small scene to connect to
bigger scenes really small touch ups but
sometimes like when you hear about the
Suicide Squad doing reshoots they'll
they'll shoot it because they want to
change some big aspect of the film but
for the most part now that they're
editing Doctor Strange you can expect to
hear more about the film they'll
probably attach the first teaser for it
to Captain America Civil War when that
drops in theaters that's the beginning
of May but really what I want to talk
about is Doctor Strange the oath you
know why Benedict Cumberbatch's holding
it up here and what it means for the
film it's not necessarily a spoiler for
the film because I'll explain what
happens during that story it's a really
good retelling of his origin story but
the cast that they've announced for the
film has some characters that are not
part of that oath story so what I think
they did and this is true of all the
Marvel films is it the story of the
movie borrows from a bunch of different
doctor strange comics but most notably I
think they'll borrow some structural
elements from Doctor Strange goes
because it tells the origin story in a
really interesting way but if you've
seen the doctor strange animated movie
it's more of a straight-up linear
telling where he gets in the accident
looks for a cure to heal his hands
enzyme eating the ancient one that
eventually becomes the sorcerer supreme
so the movie is going to cover all that
stuff but Marvel has essentially
abandoned the linear origin story so
even though they're introducing new
characters and they have to tell their
backstories they're finding creative
ways to do that so just to explain the
oath comic this is actually really good
comic to read if you haven't read it yet
what happens is as you pick up with
night nurse treating doctor strange for
injuries that he suffered in battle
while she's treating him she learns
about his origin so even though it's a
Doctor Strange comic night nurse is kind
of the protagonist because she's hearing
this story and the really cool thing is
that the origin story isn't even the
biggest story of this comic the big a
story is the Doctor Strange learns that
his servant his closest friend Wang has
an inoperable brain tumor so he looks
for a cure
finds it in another dimension the
villain of the story is not the villain
of the Doctor Strange movie which is why
I don't think they're adapting the comic
but the villain of the comic is this
pharmaceutical CEO who says it be
disastrous if dr. strange were to
release the cure for cancer into the
world so he hired someone to steal the
cure for cancer from Doctor Strange so
that he can prevent it from getting out
into the world and in the end it's
almost destroyed there's one drop left
so strange has to choose whether to use
the last little bit of it to replicate
more so that he can help humanity so he
can cure cancer for good all over the
world or cure his friend who is dying on
the spot at his feet as he's sitting
there Wong is dying he's trying to
decide what to do the villain of the
story reminds him that as a doctor he
took a Hippocratic oath to treat any
patient in his care strange chooses to
help his friend in a very Kirk Spock
kind of moment where the needs of the
one outweigh the needs of the many
therefore giving the villain what he
wants the cure for cancer isn't going to
be replicated they won't benefit
humanity but dr. strange has saved his
friend so it's kind of a touching story
where strange has to make this huge
sacrifice in order to save his friend so
great victory comes at great price so I
feel like they're gonna do something
similar to that in the Doctor Strange
movie where he has the power of an
infinity gem and they've been making it
seem like he has the time gem so imagine
he has power over time in the movie but
he has an a/b choice to make Ray has to
pick between the needs of the one and
the needs of the many I like how it all
comes back to Star Trek so you've seen
the pictures of chiwetel ejiofor he's
playing Baron Mordo he's a very
important Doctor Strange villain who it
looks like he's actually working with in
the movie the real villain of the movie
is being played by mass mickelson I
believe he's playing Dormammu who you
know much bigger villain Baron Mordo but
I think more dough would be the ultimate
villain of the sequel if you've never
read the comics it's not like Captain
America and Winter Soldier where they
start out as friends but become enemies
Mordo always resents dr. strange because
he's an outsider and like all villains
having daddy issues when the sorcerer
supreme chooses Doctor Strange as his
successor it causes this huge rift and
that's when they become full-blown
enemies so expect to see some version of
that story in the movie but I think
they'll tell it in a roundabout way like
they do during the oath I don't think
there's been any pictures of her and
stoom but Tilda Swinton is actually
playing the ancient one which i think is
a really interesting twist on the
casting but here's my big question for
you guys just like they did with ant-man
and some of the smaller Marvel films
they do tie in with the Avengers
franchise but in really small ways how
do you think that we'll see dr. strange
tie in with the other Marvel films the
interesting thing about the oath comic
that I was talking about is that there
are a lot of defenders characters in
there so you have iron fist you have
daredevil because Doctor Strange is part
of the defenders in the comics that's
not going to be the case in the movie
universe the netflix stuff is connected
to the movies but really only lightly i
think we'll only see them cross over in
Avengers infinity war if you guys miss
the captain america video that i just
posted i talked a little bit about
what's going on this week there are some
things that are on break so there's some
bonus videos that I'm working on there
is a new episode of agents of shield so
i'll post a video for that later there's
a flash bonus video that I'm working on
so what I'll probably do is I'll post
the flash bonus video next then i'll
post agents of shield on youtube i know
there was a question about agents of
shield last week i posted a bonus video
to my facebook page if you miss that the
address is facebook.com / emergency
awesome over the most part agents of
shield for the rest of the season will
post to my youtube channel while you
guys wait for me to post that next video
you can click here for my Black Panther
versus Captain America video and you can
click here for all my other captain
america civil war videos thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you